if I look at MIT today and reflect back
on 1976 when I came here um it's an
entirely different place I was the only
woman on the faculty at SLO they had
never been a woman head of Department
never been a woman Associated de or
whatever even less a woman president I
was of an age and uh status I guess
where I was asking for very very little
and I was old enough to realize I wasn't
asking for anything compared to what
most people had and I couldn't get it
and that was what finally really made me
understand that um I couldn't escape
this problem Nancy Hopkins became
conscious that it was harder for women
to do well at MIT is there something
about about their gender that is getting
in the way of their being taken
seriously I sat down one day and wrote a
letter to President vest and I said you
know there's a terrible chronic problem
in this institution I'm sure you don't
know about it because if you did you'd
certainly want to fix it and so I
described some aspects of what I thought
was discrimination against women
preventing them from doing science the
way they should be able to and I showed
it to a friend of mine he said you can't
send that to the president of MIT he
won't know what the heck that means
he'll throw it right out and he'll think
badly of you what ever so I thought okay
I'll run this by a woman scientist
another woman and ask her what she
thinks and make sure it's not offensive
and won't offend president vest so I
took I chose a person who was a very
successful scientist but I didn't know
very well because I wanted a very
objective opinion if whether this was a
polite reasonable letter I asked her to
read it she reads the letter she says
I'd like to sign this letter and I'd
like to go with you to see President
vest because I agree with everything you
said here and I said you
do
it was going to be difficult to
establish sort of statistically that
that these women were being
disadvantaged but you thought at least
if you could have uh find out some data
about their situation you could find out
something about their salaries something
about the amount of space they were
getting and resources we decided to
asked for a committee that would gather
the data in a very systematic way and
tried to explain to the dean so he could
understand it so he could fix it I
distinctly remember the the journey to
the Dean's office and we had no idea
what was going to happen but he listened
bino appointed a committee with one
woman from each of the Departments
except math and he couldn't appoint a
woman from math because they didn't have
one it was great to have men as members
of the committee because they were with
us on this women with the the ability to
do great things should be given the
opportunity do to do great things and
there shouldn't be any distinction or
any any hindrance to that Nancy famously
had a tape measure which she took and
actually measured square feet of spaces
it was really amazing to watch her in
action we presented this to our de to
the pr to the president
what came out of that study was the
feeling of a kind of pattern of
systematic minimizing of the role of
women particularly after they got
tenured my main goal was how can we make
this a report so we can get it out to
the faculty and lot he read it and he
said this must be published I asked the
chair of the faculty to send it to the
president and see if he wanted to write
something to go with it because we
didn't want MIT to look as if they'd
been blindsided cuz they hadn't we'd
worked with them we wanted to work with
them what I said was approximately this
I said I've always believed that uh
gender bias in universities is part
perception and part reality and from
this report I've learned that it's
mostly reality quite an emotional thing
to see the president of the institution
say yes this is true this happened his
comment that he thought that
discrimination was more perception and
now realizes it's more reality was one
of the things that was picked up by all
the newspaper reports and I think made
an enormous difference a day later I
read that on the front page of the New
York Times and the front page of the
Boston Globe and then the San Francisco
Chronicle CNN and to iy
bias she's a highly respected scientist
who says she was treated like a second
class citizen by one of the most
prestigious universities in America this
could not have happened to any man in my
department it just couldn't and
Professor Nancy Hopkins complaints led
to an unlikely confession MIT acted the
way you want institutions to behave and
they acted the way a scientists and
Engineers particularly you want to
behave here are the facts this is what
we understand to be the truth we have to
stand by it and we take the consequences
what they are we know took a lot of
encourage to do what Chuck vest did he
did the right thing in a very simple way
there were a couple of days in which
Nancy and I were literally getting a
thousand or so messages a day I I've
never ever experienced anything like
this they came from first from all over
the country universities then they
started coming from researchers and
companies then they started coming from
overseas and they all said the same
thing this is my story what we did not
imaged was the response would have been
so open so transparent and so positive
the effect of the report I think was
went way beyond anything that I had
expected Clinton invited Nancy Hopkins
to the White House it put gender on the
table I mean it had never been talked
about it recommended that there be more
uh Equitable salary distribution and
recommended uh that women be put on all
the search committees increase the
number of women give women
responsibility put women position of
power uh put women committee change the
way in which you do searches without
biases I think what we accomplished was
showing that there can be mechanisms for
change that don't have to be threatening
to an institution there are ways to deal
with these kinds of things openly and
that's where Chuck Fest was so
incredibly
courageous
from the time we first give toys to a
2-year-old we're already giving boys
trucks and we're giving Girls Dolls it's
sort of the a pattern embedded in our
society which gives women a lot of
credit for being caretakers raising
their
children uh being friendly being
supportive personally of other people
but not people who would be leaders or
who would make Innovations or who would
change things uh who would have ideas
new ideas that's the role of men and I
think that this this rather subtle
discrimination between men and women is
something that every woman and when he
thinks about it every man is probably
aware of these inequities can be
repaired and they were repaired and that
one that the institution has to watch
very carefully to make sure they don't
develop we have to keep consciously
correcting for those uh small but
important biases that we all carry
around people don't even think they're
prejudiced very frequently but they are
and and part of it is because we are all
raised in in a in a m which basically
Harbor such prejudices and we are
exposed to them from a very early time
and we got to we got to clean our minds
of prejudices we have to really confront
them it's sort of hard to just go up to
a guy and say look this is a problem
what are you doing to take care of it it
has a strong parallel with racial
stereotypes but the great thing about an
intellectual Society is it should be
able to work to overcome that because
our shared values are say that we don't
want to be racist and we don't want to
be sexist we want to be unbiased and
open-minded and take people at their
value and not uh come to come with with
assumptions about what they uh their
their limitations or their qualities it
was a wonderful experience emotionally
intellectually because we had an impact
now um you know it's not at all unusual
to have women department heads and we
have you know women represent at all
levels of the administration and we had
a woman president I'm very proud of
having part of this group and I have we
have remained so good friends we call
ourselves the old
gang